عدوى الاضرابات في لبنان سرت الى قطاع
التعليم العمومي
جمال جمول المعلمه باحدى المدارس الحكوميه
تطالب على غرار زملائها بالحصول على اضافه
بالدولار على راتبها الذي تتقاضاه بالليره
وصلت
نا دائم وهذا الامر كل يوم اصعب من يوم
تقلصت اجور المعلمين منذ بدايه الازمه
الاقتصاديه باكثر من 90% من قيمتها وباتوا
يصرفون نحو ثلثها لتامين تنقلهم الى
المدارس هذا الوضع المعيشي الصعب للاساتذه
ادخل قطاع التعليم في اضرابات متكرره
واصبح معها التدريس المنزلي حاجه لكثير من
التلاميذ
اولاد ام عمر من ضمنهم فبعدما تلقوا
تعليما عن بعد خلال العامين السابقين بسبب
جائحه كورونا عطلت الاضرابات هذا العام
مسارهم التعليمي اكثر من مره
كورونا ونحن اولادنا قاعدين بالبيوت او
الاون لاين ونحن اولادنا ما استوعبوها
وحنا ومدارس رسم السنه كمان سكرت واولادنا
قاعدين بالبيوت على عمل المدارس الرسميه
تفتح تعد المدارس الرسميه مجانيه
وتقدم التعليم للبنانيين والمقيمين وتعتمد
وزاره التربيه على مساعدات الدول المانحه
لتسديد جزء من الحوافز الماليه للمعلمين
الفاقد التعليمي او التعلمي يلي كل
التلميذ وصل على خسر من منه
بفتكر سنه ثالثه بتكون قاضيه على جيل واذا
قضيت عجيل بدنا ثلاثه جيال تنرجع نجلس
ونوقف على اجرينا بالتالي نعول نحن نقدم
خطوه او خطوتين هن قدموا خطوه تنرجع والا
رايحين على كرسي تربويه الواقع الصعب
لقطاع التعليم الوطني دفع كثيرا من
التلاميذ لهجر المدارس الرسميه
فتقلصت اعداد اللبنانيين المسجلين في تلك
المدارس بنسبه 30% منذ عام 2019 ازمه
التعليم في المدارس الرسميه اللبنانيه
تبدو مفتوحه الافق فلا وزاره التربيه
قادره على تامين كافه مطالب المعلمين ولا
المعلمون قادرون على العمل برواتبه تفقد
قيمتها باستمرار ايهاب العقد الجزيره
بيروت